[Music]
my name is Mandi 4-h and I lead the
industrial AI initiative for Google
cloud thank you so much for joining
really delighted to have you here at
Google we believe that the goal of every
technology should be to enrich our lives
to take our societies our collective
humanity forward and do so in a
responsible manner so we're constantly
thinking of ways in which technology and
particularly AI can help us realize this
bright and promising future so we've
been thinking how can we apply our
advanced computer vision technology for
solving some of the very hard incumbent
problems in the industrial sectors and
how can we make these sectors more
efficient and more sustainable so in the
next 50 minutes we'll be talking about
how with industrial inspection AI that
is powered by the auto ml vision
technology can help make industrial
inspections more easier faster accurate
and more importantly more safer and
we'll also look at how to leading
companies are applying this technology
to the energy and manufacturing sector
so let's get started so AI hold great
promise for solving some real world
problems from detecting glaucoma with
retinal images to processing millions or
even billions of documents to understand
their content to automatically
moderating unsafe and inappropriate
content we are applying this technology
across all of these use case
but we also recognize that developing
this technology building these custom
vision models is laborious and it's hard
so we wanted to enable even the non
programmers to be able to tap into the
power of AI and that is precisely why we
created Auto ml vision so while our
standard ap eyes are a great powerhouse
for pre-trained models on the massive
google image datasets all ML allows you
to train custom models that are specific
to your industry needs to your use case
needs how do we do that so in a very
simple clean UI you are able to upload
the images labeled images if you're
looking to classify a problem or you can
draw bounding boxes at we as we take a
look to detect specific objects within
those images once you've done that with
a click of a button you've got a model
trained and that model can be used to
detect shark species in this case or you
can use that to detect defects anomalies
breakage in your specific industrial
products we already seeing use cases
with wind turbine degradation inspection
with outages on solar panel forms or
failures on electric poles and we'll be
looking into some of these examples in
more detail shortly at this point I want
to take a moment to talk about data
protection and privacy so your data sets
your images are your images all of these
custom trained models are used only on
your use cases by you Google does not
pull these images into any common
deposit
trees or use this across customers so
your data sets your images we'll take a
look at how this technology can be
applied for aerial inspection in wind
turbines and then an application of that
on the production line in a
manufacturing company but before I begin
there we want to share Google's stance
on the use of this technology so Google
cares deeply that it's technology is
used for creating a positive impact in
the world and in that win Google created
air principles in last June they set the
standard of the application of these air
technologies and we abide by these
principles for any work that involves AI
and similarly for the use of this
technology and for this product we
expect that this technology be applied
in accordance to the air principle which
prohibit explicitly the use of this
technology for any nefarious purposes so
we'll now take a look at how one of the
leading energy companies in the world is
applying this technology to create a
brighter and greener future for us all
let's take a look at global yes wind
turbine
inspections not the biggest you know
several times now we really do have the
technology to address the issue of
carbon footprint greenhouse gases from
the electric sector
dey's corporation is one of the leaders
in new technologies for renewables and
energy storage it's a fortune 500
company
our mission is accelerating a safer and
greener energy future right now we have
eight wind farms each farm has different
capacity starting from 50 turbines up to
300 turrets they cover large spans of
geography and land they're spread across
hilltops and mountain sides all these
turbines needs annual inspections
originally it could take up to two weeks
to do one inspection we partnered with
leading drone service company measure
right now with drones we can do it in
two days and this is safe and quick for
a wind turbine inspection we go out with
our pilots and what we're looking for is
cracks or defects things that may need
to be prepared on a typical inspection
we're coming back with 30,000 images
spending four weeks reviewing images I
don't think anyone's gonna argue that
that the best use of a highly trained
engineers time how do we speed that up
and how they make it 10x more efficient
that's where machine learning and AI
comes in we've built a great and an
solution using Google class tools and
platform with the auto amount vision
tool we've trained it to detect damage
we're able to eliminate approximately
half of the images from needing human
review remaining 50% of their time can
now be very focused on identifying that
damage and really determining the right
course of action to immediate it moving
from reviewing images to training
machine learning models it's a much
higher order employment opportunity for
people and one where we're trying to
develop on our team Google cloud has
been a great partner there technology's
consistently among the world leaders and
I'm just a great partner to work with
person-to-person at the end of the day
we won't reach the cleaner energy future
without advanced tools like machine
learning technology will allow the
renewable energy to be cheaper than
conventional ownership artificial
intelligence robotics this is really
where the future is all about
[Music]
please join me in welcoming Nico's born
from it yes Thank You Mandy and thank
you to the team that put that great
video together the power industry is
enormous it touches all of our lives and
the impacts are felt around the world
the industry investments are often
quoted in the trillions of dollars the
opportunities for improvement are often
in the billions if not tens or even
hundreds of billions of dollars the
industry is also going through
significant and profound change
renewable energy is continuing to fall
dramatically in price solar wind and
battery energy storage are not just
possible or practical the consumer is
also driving change they are much more
aware of both the opportunities and the
costs associated with their energy use
and the third megatrend
are the new digital tools cloud AI and
many others that are changing the
economics of insight I'm here today to
share one story where we've partnered
with Google to improve lives by
accelerating a safer cleaner energy
future we call this our vision or aerial
intelligence platform first a little bit
about myself and the company I work for
I'm Nick Osborne I'm the business leader
focused on understanding and applying
advanced analytic tools like artificial
intelligence and machine learning to
applied business cases jobs really quite
simple I accelerate coordinate and
facilitate the adoption of these new
tools across the organization
AES is a global power company were
headquartered in India in the United
States but operate in 15 countries
around the world we've made a very
significant commitment to reduce our
carbon intensity by 70% by the year 2030
to help us achieve this we've made some
very significant investments in new
technologies we're the world leader in
battery energy storage using lithium-ion
batteries and we're also the largest
owner of solar assessing and in the
it states on a personal note it feels
good to come home at the end of the day
and know I'm working with a company
that's putting its money where its mouth
is to drive that change that is core to
our mission applying new technologies is
core to how we operate our business our
drone program is considered world
leading in the end of in the energy
industry we developed this program by
partnering with measure measure is a
professional drone services organization
and the measure ground control software
is an enterprise caliber drone
operations platform through this
partnership we've improved the cost
safety and performance of our
inspections another consideration is
that what we often hear about the threat
of technology taking jobs or eliminating
jobs that's clearly not the case with
what we're seeing in our drone program
and many other technologies that we're
exploring we now have over a hundred and
seventy pilots trained in our
organization performing operations in
over a hundred locations around the
world these are employees with
tremendous value for our company for
their personal advancement and their
broader career growth prior to drones
these inspections were typically done
manually so it was either someone
climbing up the turbine and then
rappelling down to inspect the blade or
hiking around the turbine with a large
telephoto lens trying to capture an
angle and trying to see if they could
detect damage neither of these were as
effective or as efficient or as safe as
what we're able to do with drones
so using drones we're now able to take
that partial inspection that was taking
two weeks of time and do a full
inspection in two days a much lower cost
much higher quality and a much safer
manner tremendous improvement in
efficiency and velocity in our
organization but there was one new
workflow we're now when we do a single
turbine inspection so single turbine has
around 300 images when we do an entire
field this means we're coming back with
30,000 or even 60,000 images this takes
a lot of meticulous and detail review to
complete the inspection work
so we saw this as a great opportunity
for artificial intelligence and this is
really where our partnership with Google
started to grow to understand our
journey towards AI you need to
understand with where where we started
we started with an investment in talent
we sent two classes of six people to
Google's advanced to solution lab for
intense training and supervised machine
learning this cohort became the
foundation for our work in AI internally
we refer to this decision as a no
regrets decision meaning that we were
able to quickly move forward make this
investment with little or no hesitation
on our part a few keys for ROI is one is
don't just send IT people to this
training a lot of the value from data
science in general and this program
comes from the mixture of expertise and
ideas that you get when you send
multiple multiple types of people
through the program the second piece of
advice and this is maybe a bit selfish
on my part is make sure you have a good
commitment to work on your projects
after this training we only sent
high-performing individuals to the
training and the risk with sending
high-performing individuals is that
they're going to get quickly pulled back
into their day job and that's definitely
something we had to work through as an
organization so this investment set the
groundwork to accelerate our progress
that we were making as a company and is
another example of where new
technologies are increasing
opportunities for our employees so from
this foundation we got to work we went
through a proof pilot production process
with each step being a stage gate for
further investment so starting with our
proof we built a custom tensor flow
model leveraging the openly available
inception v3 vision model and it worked
we were able to detect damage but it
also showed us where our shortcomings
were our data needed work and setting up
the end-to-end platform was going to be
difficult and we were going to need some
help so in speaking with Google about
our progress and our learnings we
discussed the possibility of partnering
on a pilot phase so in the pilot phase
we are we are
were labeling sorry we were using
Google's data labeling service and
Google's Auto mail vision tool to really
accelerate our efforts and boost our
efficiency and again it worked false
negatives were seen as a key business
risk for our organization so not
detecting damage is something that we
weren't willing to accept in our
inspection process so using our most
restrictive precision recall metrics
during this pilot phase we were able to
show that we could eliminate 30% of the
images from needing any human review so
that four-week review process was now
down to three works three weeks really
accelerating our velocity and our time
to action time to action has really
become one of those key metrics that we
look at with this project so this gave
us the commitment our yeah commitment
and ability to move forward with our
production environment so our production
environment is a scalable platform for
us to label images train new models and
manage those models in production we're
still iterating and refining on this
model but we're again showing some very
promising results we're now showing that
we can eliminate 50% of the images from
needing any human review and the
remaining 50% of the images are now
categorized and classified by type of
damage further improving our time to
action and focusing our engineers on the
most important and most critical types
of damage so going back to data one of
the things that we had learned about
early on was that our data all we had a
lot of data that was not at the quality
or level of consistency we needed for
machine learning so working with measure
we developed in nine category
classification of damage this includes
things like cracks gel coat damage
different types of delamination and
splitting as well as some non damage
categories like serial numbers lightning
protection points stickers and whatnot
so we also worked with Google's data
labeling team to iterate and walk
through many many edge cases of
different types of damage that are out
there we started with a series of
batches small in size doing a full and
complete review of all the labels that
were coming back
but as the quality of labeling improved
and our batch sizes improved we've moved
towards a sample basis we also needed to
develop a platform to manage the
labeling effort model training
prediction process working with Google
we identified clear object to be a local
GCP partner to help us architect and
develop our platform using the latest
thinking and cloud and serverless tools
available from Google clear object has
been a great partner and work to quickly
develop this platform for us the
platform leverages Auto ml for our core
modeling engine cloud storage and cloud
SQL for our image repository and
metadata as well as cloud functions and
app engine for to manage our
interactions and orchestrations so now
that we have this platform we're
continuing to improve on the model or
we're also looking to expand its use
we're looking at new business cases
solar transmission infrastructure and
even safety as well as looking at new
inspection modalities for example
infrared and even lidar we're also
looking at pushing the model to the edge
or in this case the drone so I'm really
excited to hear about what LG is going
to be sharing next energy is a trillion
dollar business it impacts lives in
every day in every country around the
world the challenge and the real-world
impact are huge if you're interested in
working with or for company that is
improving lives by accelerating a safer
cleaner energy future please come talk
to me
mandeep
[Applause]
thank you very much make for that great
presentation so we saw how Auto ml
version can be used for visual
inspections to make them more easy
faster accurate and safer in speaking
with lot of experts from the industry we
learned that there are some specific
requirements for manufacturing use case
a lot of a time this data sits on
premise there's latency requirements and
most of the image and data sets are in a
format that requires it to be processed
on the edge devices this be a mobile
phone this be an edge TPU a CPU or a GPU
so with our Auto ml version on edge
solution you're able to take your custom
trained model and then download them in
an edge device and you can run those
inferences from your edge devices
I think you'd much rather see that in
action and hear directly from a
manufacturing company which has deployed
these models on the production line so
it's a great pleasure for me to invite
mr. soon book leave from LG and share
more about this initiative mr. Lee a
good afternoon everyone I'm very thank
you for your attention to our previous
presentation my name is Tom Oakley and
the vice-president of AI and picked a
business unit at LG's Janice it seems
there are many Isis fascists in our
audience today I think if you are like
me I expect we share many great hopes to
apply AI tulear word assertions
I also hope this short overview our
collaboration with Google Auto ml will
help you all in your AI work today we'll
be looking at how additional send
Coogler has successfully collaborated on
hey I immediately commission
technologies and how we have been apply
our leisure to pigeon inspection systems
and several manufacturing solutions
let's begin with a little background
over jeez Janice I think you may know
the name of LG group but you don't know
about it what kinds of companies in the
energy group so I want to introduce some
companies we have LG Electronics which
produces the television and refrigerator
and we have LG Display a produces world
reading or LED panel and the LG Innotech
produces a camera model so I think a
half of you the have already the LG no
text camera in your cell phone
oh sorry smartphone and LG Chemical
produces electric battery is another and
world reading company under age group so
you may know that almost all the LG
group company is working in the
manufacturing industry as LG sentences
supplies the IT solutions for the LG
group affiliates and other companies the
working in the manufacturing industry we
are constantly working on how to best
apply a high technology to improve the
manufacturing processes and we all know
that it can be really challenged to use
the big data and AI technology to ensure
product quality on a largest scale
production this is where our discussion
of a Google or ml comes in today edition
has started working with the Google team
l in the summer of last year we started
our collaboration after seeing the
Google was achieving in their immediate
recognition technology because we
thought Google or ml could help to
improve vision inspection for LG
production processes and to our great
satisfaction our collaboration has been
a success
okay before we work with Google ultramel
actually we had already developed our
own in-house AI system a photos of you
familiar with the manufacturing process
you will like clear recognize that the
picture the left of the screen is the
typical visual inspection system that
reliance relies on the human operators
while many production lines can't have a
camera and IOT sensors and other
detection technologies but non while the
many production lines can use camera but
it is still hard to find the rear defect
efficiently sometimes non defective
product open misjudged as defective
because of minor factors like a small
dust particles or low resolution images
and it is still more effective rely on
people to complete visual inspections
and while people get better the Ridgid
that monotony of a visual inspection
made by workers also lead to many errors
as well to solve this problem
indigenous made a tradition we moved
from the traditional visual inspection
the left image II you can see to the AI
inspection system shown on the right I'm
sure many of you also working on the
inspection technologies so you will be
familiar the Trier and era Mossad we
need to improve our system with
artificial intelligence anyway within
our with our in-house system we increase
the accuracy and performance and even
improved our process speed and
efficiency it means that we could reduce
our the operation costs or zone
with our in-house AI system we were able
to apply to over the three production
lines only in age group some of these
include the first picture as you can see
we could improve the defect detection in
LCD and LED panels and under the middle
of the picture we could remove in
pretties from the optical Trillium and
even improving the quality control for
the production so about automotive
efflux can be made with our in-house AI
system but even with this improvement
our system wasn't working optimally
because it still requires a lot of time
and effort to perform well and now I
will talk about a little about the
downside of this system as it's often
the case with the success we also ran
into some obstacles as we expanded the
application of our AI pigeon inspection
into other area we have experienced a
shortage of skilled AI developers it is
very hard to hire the good AI developers
for the company they're located in South
Korea so it is very hard times when the
one a I developers leave our company the
parry impetus is so big to our company
so and while we designed the AI model
they need to spend a lot of time and
effort to achieve high performance
additionally as we develop the model
using service located at the production
site the compressed T of architecture
has been increased so it is hard to be
served so now we require
the process to sentry design and this
treat the model to the edgy and to
centrally control the the performance of
the deployed model in one integrity
system
collaboration with Google has been a
critical to find the solution to these
problems the performance of Google
ultramel has been truly exciting even
though our the AIS person doesn't like
it one of the key areas we need to
improve in our system was our
productivity in terms of the moral
development time as you can see in the
diagram on the left our top arrow bar
shows it took roughly seven days to
complete our model before using ultramen
but afterwards we brought that down to a
mere two two hours with Google Reutimann
the other area we need to improve was
the accuracy of our system in addition
to being faster from the diagram on the
right pictured Google automates
performance exceeded that of the AI
experts in many times our test lizard
showed the average is six percent
improvement in terms of performance we
can expect when using a Google chairman
I think while we have made advances
using Google or ml and integrating that
with our visual inspection we are still
facing several challenges in many cases
we could not meet our clients
requirement and you found that the many
of them comes from the low image quality
not from the model that we made with the
Google
so to solve this problem we listen to
launch it immediate pre-processing
lizards team the members of this team
spend more time on exploratory data
analysis and pre-processing data and try
how to try hard to augment data for
getting better machine learning models
so they became to spend a lot of time on
thinking how to the changing the
inspection process itself I estimate now
our members could use their time and
effort for more strategy work now we are
planning to expand our business into
consulting services so we will provide
expertise to enhanced in to enhance
overall inspection processes as a
one-stop solution we are hopeful that we
will see the first manufacturing visual
inspection area where humans and a I
share areas the least panzerotti very
optimally do you agree ok I would like
to announce that we have built
integrated AI a vision inspection
architecture so our system and Google
ultramel is connected seamlessly with
this architecture we will be able to
maximize humans capability and
utilization of Google or ml this
architecture starts from the data
scientist past the bottom they will
ensure a major quality so they will
produce a clear image and will send to
the Google or travel and Google Tom a
text a clear image and produced a a
model with efficiency
and with effectiveness awesome the
Morris will be completely managed with
all the history data and performance
status and automated learning processes
with this architecture the elegiggle is
now developed now can developed and
managing thousands of a aia morris
simultaneously in addition to vision
inspection our goal is to expand the
architecture to the other the
manufacturing use cases to manage the
whole factory equipment facilities and
the safe things and so on i think you
may think however many use cases we can
expand this instrument architecture in
the manufacturing industry to this point
we have gone over how collaboration with
google Tramel has improved our visual
inspection systems now let's look at a
to the future based on our AI
integration success with within the edge
group we will keep going to be
positioned as leading AI visual
inspection total service provider so we
recover from the pre-processing area and
we will cover learning the model and
then we will manage all the Morris melt
with Google attainment
whether the cause of poor inspection
quality is motion running attainment
over the image quality or data labeling
over the operators themselves working
with Google ml we will strive to achieve
our goal of 99.9 percent accuracy and
the leak Lake of 0.001 percent under all
conditions
if you were experiencing the similar
issues in your industry I hope that this
session could be helpful I really
appreciate your attention and thank you
for listening thank you
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Lee so the goal that mr.
Lee shared about LG is very much what we
share for our product and for our
roadmap as well which is to make our
inferences faster our interfaces more
intuitive and easier and our results
more accurate within manufacturing we
seeing many more use cases beyond
automotive beyond electronics into the
food into retail and many more
categories and we are very excited to
work on these new use cases with you we
saw how a eye and visual inspection can
be applied to the manufacturing use
cases and we looked at how this can be
applied for the aerial inspection use
cases beyond the three use cases that we
talked about on the aerial inspection
side we are also exploring more work on
the agriculture monitoring and
construction site monitoring as of today
this technology is available to use in
Bera
please visit cloud.google.com slash
vision to register your interest you can
use the technology right away but by
registering at this site we are able to
partner with you and work with you on
our upcoming releases and our early
access program so we look forward to
hearing from you thank you so much for
joining us in this shared vision and we
really look forward to working with you
in creating a more brighter more greener
and more positive future thank you very
much all
[Applause]
[Music]